[Music]
my name is perang I am a professor
emeritus of University of Upsala and
also a consultant at the University
Hospital of Upsala presently I'm the CEO
of Diagnostics
development my research interest during
many years that has been to purify novel
proteins from Nils and eosinophils and
also to make assays for these four
diagnostic
purposes what I will try to do today
that is to show you the many diagnostic
potentials of one of these proteins that
is human nutrii lipocalin
H&L H&L has many clinical
applications viral bacterial distinction
sepsis monitoring acute kidney injury
diagnosis can be used in covid for
prediction and also in inflammatory
bowel disease and irritable bowel
syndrome but before we start to um
discuss these clinical application there
is something you have to understand and
that is that H&L exists in several
molecular forms in various fluids of the
human body in fact we have both D
monomeric forms dieric forms and
heteromeric
forms and this is Illustrated in this uh
simply by making Western blotting of
urin and nutrii release products and
epithelial cells
uh the interesting thing is that the
monomeric hnl is produced by epithelial
cells as well as by neutri whereas and
this is very important dimeric hnl is
produced only by
neutri this slide is an example of the
differences of uh these various forms we
have collected the plasma and serum from
two patients with different kinds of
infections that is influenza A and
bacterial infections and what you can
see here is that in the influenza A
patient both in plasan serum you have
the monomeric you have the diic and also
some homic H&L whereas in the bacterial
disease the dominating protein here is
actually the diare and that is what is
produced by the neutri fills
by means of our monoclonal antibodies
and polyclonal antibodies we have been
able to combine these in many different
ways uh which has enabled us to make
unique assays of H&L and its different
forms one of the more spectacular
variants of this is um the making of an
alyer that uniquely measures the H&L
dier and in this slide I show you with
the blue U the dimeric H&L protein
measured by this Elisa and you can see
there's a nice uh curve whereas if we
try to measure the monomeric hnl with
this lyser we fail there is no signal at
all
so to um summarize a bit of of the
of H&L we can say that H&L human
nutripan is actually it has many
different names engga lipocalin 2o and
even others but it's the same gene
product and when we purified
H&L at the same
time the group of Nils borod in
Copenhagen purified this protein and
called it
engar
so as I said it exists in several
molecular forms in plasma and other
biological
fluids and the cellular origins of hnl
are nutrifil and epithelial
cells the dimeric form of hnl is unique
to nuts whereas the monic form
originates from both cell types and in
most cases it's not preformed in the
epithelial cells but uh it has to be
induced by various
mechanisms and what I also said is that
the combination of H&L maps and PS gives
rise to Unique possibilities to
construct unique imuno assays with
different clinical diagnostic
targets so let us turn into the clinical
applications first of all and to me uh
still is the most important clinical
application that is the distinction
between bacterial and viral
disease and for that purpose we have can
measure hnl in serum in plasma or after
whole blood activation whole blood
activation means that we take 5 10
microl of whole blood and then put an
activator of Nutri Fields into that and
then we measure what is released
from the nut
fils and uh these
different assays they are actually
Superior diagnostic tools to distinguish
between bacterial and viral
infections and all with the aim to
reduce antibiotics
abuse there is a catch here with serum
measurements
since obtaining serum
for the measurement of hnl requires
actually strict standardization of blood
sampling procedure as to time and
temperature if you are not very strict
you can have both falsely high and
falsely low
levels and for that purpose as I already
mentioned we developed a whole blood
activation procedure that completely
eliminates this problem and the good
good thing about this is that when we
measure hnl released by whole in the
whole blood blood
activation uh procedure then it's very
well correlated to serum obtained in a
strict a standardized
fashion one example of serum
measurements is this one where we have
obtained a number of
patients with acute infections caused by
virus or bacteria the samples were
obtained before antibiotics treatment
and the patients diagnosis were
confirmed by myology and PCR
Etc and as you can see here uh in the
left panel in the middle there then it's
patients with bacterial infections and
to the left and to the right you have
have results from patients with viral
infection and healthy
subjects we compared this also to other
U current uh measures that is CRP and
nutrifield counts and to the right you
can see Rock curves of U these assays
and their clinical
performances and obviously the blue line
here representing the H&L essay is uh
very close to the upper left corner
which uh indicates that it might be
ideal for this kind of
discrimination and uh below you can see
also the figures that we obtain with hnl
a negative predictive value of
98% and a positive predictive value of
93% and obviously significantly
different from other currently used
assays
I will also show you another very small
study on bacterial enviral
pneumonia in a hospitalized
population because this this gives us an
idea of how we can use not only for
diagnosis and
distinction uh this H&L we can also
monitor
successful uh antibiotics treat treat M
and here you can see that when if
patients had taken their antibiotics 3 4
days before they were admitted to the
hospital then the levels were obviously
lower and in some cases
normal so that
was serum results now I will show you
some results from the whole blood
activation procedure and here I will
show you two things that are quite
interesting first of all if we just base
the diagnosis on clinical data including
nutrii counts and CRP then we do not
have any very good distinction
between CRP and H&L non significant
although H&L and PCT they are
inct but if we base the diagnosis on
confirmed
iology that is bacterial growth and and
uh PCR or virus Etc then you can see
that that the blue line here which
represents H&L actually goes up and
approaches again the upper left
corner and Below you can see the
statistics here that H&L now
distinguishes
itself against CRP with a high P value
as H&L does when it comes to
PCT so this is very important to
understand that when we we do
evaluations of these kinds of marker we
need to have uh confirmed U athology and
diagnosis of the
patients we also um measure measured in
um a number we measured a number of
other plasma based markers and combined
them with the whole blood activated H&L
because after all we didn't obtain 100%
separation distinction between bacterial
and viral disease so we asked ourselves
can
we get even closer to 100%
distinction uh C P
only in this material I I had an area on
the Rock curve about
75% and the whole
blood system had an area under the rock
curve of more than
90% but you can see that the red uh bar
here there we have added
Trail uh and actually we approach
100% we we uh do not show this in this
particular slide but with ip10 we could
show a similar
thing we also made made um a ranking of
the individual individual assets here
for the distinction and discrimination
between bacterial and viral respiratory
infections and and uh it's again very
important to emphasize that all
infections were
confirmed by the
ethology and here you can see that Serum
hnl is
actually in the
top
ER but as I said before it requires
strict stand
standardized uh blood sampling and
preparation of the of the blood
to obtain
serum a reliable
serum blood
activated uh H&L comes next and then
comes nutfield tray IP 10 plasma H&L CRP
and far down below PCT and heparin
binding protein and thymidines
so also as individual as says
HL uh me measured in either way are the
superior
ones next that is
sepsis and
U for sepsis our
favorite assay is the H&L diare that is
the
H&L assay that reflects the involvement
of
nutrifield we can also use whole blood
hnl in whole blood after activation to
to
U
distinguish
uh from other diagnosis predict the
outcome but most of all and most
importantly for therapy
monitoring and here is one example of
that here you can see that that um those
patients with with sepsis they
have much higher levels than those
patients with a bacterial pneumonia or
those patients with a viral
pneumonia and
influenza and um of course they were all
elevated as compared to
normals but if we made Rock curves and
if we measured PCT procalcitonin in the
same material we could not show actually
that H&L was Superior to procalcitonin
in the sepsis versus
viral influence a
distinction nor could we show that it
separated the sepsis from bacteria
better than than uh PCT our HL
dier and if we look at some of the other
biomarkers you can again see that the
area under the curve of the H&L variance
are above 8 as is PCT whereas the other
assays Cal protectin Hein binding
protein CRP are clearly below
that one important thing when it comes
to sepsis that is prediction how can we
know which patient will end up with a
severe sepsis or even die from their
sepsis and who won't sofa score is is a
score of the severity of sepsis and if
you have
sofa above seven and up to even to 14 14
you are you are
certainly about to die then you have a
very severe
sepsis and what was interesting is that
if we measure the H&L diir in a cohort
of patients and related that to sofa
score then you can see that those with
sofa more than seven had significantly
higher levels at the day of sepsis
diagnosis this is long before they
actually developed the severe signs of
sepsis and even died this was not the
case for PCT as you see in the right
panel where there's really no uh
significant difference between the two
groups we suffer more or less than
seven one of one of
the very
important
things when it comes to sepsis that is
monitoring of antibiotics
treatment because you want to know when
you start to treat a patient with sepsis
does this antibiotic IC work or
not and that is a very tricky thing
because these patients are multi sick
and it's a very complicated clinical
situation they are living in and to our
surprise and to our really
uh we were quite happy when we saw that
the dieric H&L was reduced within 24
hours after adequate
antibiotics and stayed so and made came
became even lower later
on
U this is actually quite quite uh
unique because when you look at other
assays PCT for example which has been
used for this purpose then we couldn't
see that PCT was reduced earlier than
four days after initiation of adequate
antibiotics uh the total levels of hnl
was not altered CRP was not affected Cal
protectin was not was not affected but
the HL H&L dier
was very rapidly
reduced as a consequence of antibiotics
treatment and this can also be shown for
the individual septic patients here you
have on the left the dimeric
H&L which very regularly is reduced
after adequate antibiotics whereas on
the right side you can see
procalcitonin which does not show this
kind of
regular reduction some goes up and some
goes down down there is no significant
uh
change now acute kidney injury and
covid that's another major indication
for
H&L and it's not so surprising for you
maybe because as I said initially H&L is
the same gene product as
engal
so we measure H&L in plasma and in urine
and we have shown that it's a tool for
diagnosis for monitoring and also for
prediction this slide is quite
interesting and this illustrates what I
talked about
before here we have five
different H&L assay yeah one assay is
actually the nalay from
R&D but they are supposed to measure the
same thing that is hn or engal in
plasma but what you can see that by
changing the conformation of these
assays as to
antibodies catching antibodies detecting
antibodies then these assays actually
pick up very different uh levels of
H&L and the one that U is most striking
here is the format 7638 F that actually
picks up most of all these whereas the
HL dier is picks
up 10 times
less and we we um have used these uh
compare these assays in patients with
acute kidney
injury and uh this is from a covid
uh patient cohort at their admission to
the ICU and they were of course admitted
to the ICU because they had respir Pro
respiratory problems and some also had
signs of organ failure as such
as acute kidney
injury and what you see here in the left
panel is that this assay 76 c8f actually
is very closely related to K kigo kigo
is um a collective U algorithm of the
severity of kidney
injury so k iGo 3 are the ones who have
are the most severely ill
patients but you couldn't see that with
engal at day
one and if you
um transfer this into rock curves again
then you can see that the 7638 F
actually predicted survival fairly good
not perfect an area on the curve of
Point 76 but significantly different
from engal and also from the DI
assay the severity of Aki actually there
the dier and 7638 F assets were similar
similarly related but again engal was
less related to severe Aki
then these patients were sampled day
three and of course they had a
progression in their organ failures such
as a kidney and you can see this again
that those with kdo 3 they had the very
highly raised levels of
H&L and if we again transfer this into
rock curves then you can see that as to
survival prediction now engal is not
different from H&L whereas still the
severity of um Aki is more closely
related to the levels of hnl total
7638 as opposed to
engar then I would like to show you this
because I I think this data is is very
intriguing
um at the time when Co was was uh
reasonably young we understood that the
co infection did
something to the body that we didn't uh
recognize from other
infections and uh the idea and the
findings suggested that maybe the Nils
are involved in this process as well and
U we set out to to investigate this in a
large fairly large Co cohort and since
we had the tools to measure nutrii
involvement either by plasma levels of
H&L dier or by activation of whole blood
we looked at this then and what you can
see here is it's it may be very
difficult to see but we had a certain
cut off and related
or
predicted severe Aki stage three by 40%
in those subjects who
was was above this cut
off and when we looked at the activated
whole blood H&L then we predicted by
60% those who actually developed Aki
stage three uh during these 50 days of
observations the last clinical
application I I would like to to talk to
you about that is um H&L in inflammatory
bowel disease and in irritable bow
syndrome you may know that irritable
bowel syndrome is Maybe
the most common uh complaint of all uh
human beings it has been estimated that
IBS from its most severe form to its
mildest forms affect uh 20% of the
humanity but nothing is known or very
little is known about the pathopysiology
of
IBS however
when we do this we measure H&L in
feces and for that it's potentially
useful tool for both diagnosis and for
monitoring of IBS and
IBD here you can see that the when we
measure with our H&L PB 765
essay then those with crohn's disease CD
have significantly higher levels than
healthy subjects as do those with
ulcerative colitis and that is not
unexpected we know that these two
diseases are driven by
nutrifil this the surprising thing is
that IBS
is much higher in the than the healthy
subjects we made Rock curves and you can
see that distinction between IBD and
healthy persons Cal protecting is what
is is being used today but the H&L PS
765 and even Mo seem to be slightly
better for this
uh when it comes to distinction between
IBS and healthy persons then C
protecting does nothing it's it's
similar
between these two cohorts edn the
eosinophil derived neurotoxin is
actually significantly higher indicating
an eosinophil component in this disease
but what is really striking that is H&L
which is at at least two fold higher in
IBS than in healthy subjects and M is
not at
all and if you make rock curve you can
can see that the only assay that really
shines here that is H&L P
765 whatever that
means and also we have a relation to
subtypes of IBS so the constipation type
the diarrhea type the mix type they have
higher levels of
hnl so finally the many clinical
applications of
H&L they
are bacterial viral Superior distinction
by whole blood activation of serum it's
sepsis prediction and therapy monitoring
by plasma H&L dier it's acute kidne
injury monitoring and outcome prediction
by plasma and
urine it's covid outcome prediction and
diagnosis of organ failure by plasma
urine or whole blood activation and IBD
IBS identification of unique activities
in ibas byis analysis and probably much
more is to be found thank you very
much